The inverse of this function would be negative 1,5, 3, negative 2, and 2,6.
Great thinking if you found these three coordinates. Now, what you want to
notice is that the inputs and the outputs switch for the inverse function. In
other words, notice how a, b, and c were always the input for the first
function we looked at. Whereas in the inverse function, a, b and c were all
outputs. Another way of thinking about it is that the x and y coordinate always
switched. So, here for x I had a, and for y I had 2. In the inverse function
the x value is 2 and the y value is a. This is also true for these other two
points. The x value and the y value switched. The same was true for this last
point. So, to find this inverse function we simply switch the x and the y
values for each coordinate pair. That's how we wind up with this function. Keep
in mind that inverse functions undo the original function. So, if I put in 5, I
get an output of negative 1. So, to undo that, when I put in my negative 1 to
my inverse, I want to get out the output of 5, the original input.